Let's get started.
A couple of announcements.
A remember about the Periodic Table
test which will be added next week
on the 23rd. You can see the
website if you want to download a
copy of this to practice on it.
You are required only to put the
one or two-letter chemical
abbreviation, the symbol.
Some people ask me if I want you to
know the molecular weights and so on,
and I thought that
was bit excessive.
So I think if you just know the
symbols for the ones that are up
there, that would be just dandy.
Here is the lady's scarf, very hot,
black. See, trim lines, blue and
gold, and it has elements on it.
Very hot. And there is a necktie,
comparable fabric, comparable
pattern. It is not geeky.
This is very hot.
You need this. Let's get on with
the lesson. Last day we looked at
Rutherford, Geiger,
Marsden and the experiment that they
conducted on the gold foil.
And out of that came the
recognition that Thompson's plum
pudding model is not sustainable in
the light of this evidence.
And in its stead Rutherford
proposed something akin
to a planetary system.
And there is something I would like
you to be tuned into here.
People to this day are looking for
a theory of everything.
And there is something very
appealing about the notion that the
rules that govern the motion of
heavenly bodies might be applicable
down at atomic dimensions.
This is very cosmic. There is a
gestalt here. We ended the day with
Bohr's model of the atom,
which derived from the
conceptualization of Rutherford.
And this model is quantitative.
And I think I put up the postulates.
And what I am going to do today is
go in some detail through the Bohr
model, so let's do that.
I am going to put up the most
primitive version.
It is a one electron atom.
It has a nucleus at the center
charged positively.
This is where most of the mass
resides and the positive
charge resides.
And orbiting around this is a lone
electron out at some distance r.
And I don't have to worry about
these relative dimensions because we
know from Marsden's calculations
that, on the length scale that I
have shown here,
these would be just tiny little dots.
It is about 10,
00 to one, the ratio of the nuclear
dimension to the entire atomic
dimension. And so we have a
positive charge in the nucleus which
is given by the number of protons.
This is a one electron atom.
It could be hydrogen,
it could be helium plus,
it could be lithium double plus and
so on. These are all one electron
atoms, and they are gas,
a single atom. This will be Z times
the elementary charge.
Remember, e represents the
elementary charge,
not the charge on the electron.
The charge on the electron is minus
e. This is Z times e in the center.
And out here we have the charge on
the electron as simply equal to e.
I am going to highlight this by
calling this q1,
lower case q being the charge here
on the nucleus.
And lower case q sub 2 is the
charge on the electron.
And that is given by minus e.
And so the other thing that we
consider is the nucleus as being
stationary. We have an orbiting
electron but a stationary nucleus.
And Rutherford, who I have already
described to you as being a little
bit colorful in his language,
backed up Bohr on this.
He said when an elephant has fleas
it is the fleas that do the jumping.
That is why we don't worry about
the motion of the nucleus because
the ratio of mass is about 2,
00 to one. What I am going to do is
use these postulates and go through
the basis for the Bohr model.
The first thing we are going to do
is describe the energy of the system.
The total energy of the system,
which we are going to get from
postulate number four,
which says the energy of the
electron, which is the energy of the
system, is the sum of the kinetic
and the potential energy.
Let's write that.
And, as I reminded you at the end
of last day, the only reason I am
doing this for you right now is I
want to elucidate the principles.
It is not because I favor
derivations in class.
I've been teaching long enough to
know that doing derivations in class
is equivalent to pouring ice water
on the proceedings,
so I do this sparingly.
It is a Newtonian system from the
mechanical standpoint.
This is going to have one-half mv
squared where this is the mass of
the electron. And then the
potential energy,
the energy is stored here due to the
coulombic force of attraction
between the electron and the nucleus.
So, in the most general form,
Coulomb's law is the product of the
charge, q1q2 divided by their
separation, which is r.
And, in order to rationalize
electrostatic units with mechanical
units, we have to put
a factor in here.
Otherwise, the units that come out
of this calculation won't dovetail
with the units that come out of this
calculation. And that factor is 4
pi times epsilon zero.
Epsilon zero is the permittivity of
vacuum. And now we can plug in q1
and q2. We know that we have
one-half mv squared.
And then q1 is plus qe,
q2 is minus e.
So then that will give us a net
minus Z times the square of the
elementary charge over 4 pi epsilon
zero r. And I am going to label
this as equation one.
And so this is really a mechanical
term, if you like,
and this is electrostatic or
coulombic. I am going to use
different words for that.
And where do we find these things?
You can find values of all of these
if you look at your
Table of Constants.
This is the table of constants in
its entirety. If you look up really
close, there is the elementary
charge e. There is the mass of the
electron. All of these are given
here. This is 9.
1 times 10 to the minus 31 kilograms.
It is 1.6 times 10 to minus 19
coulombs. There is the permittivity
vacuum. It is all up there.
So you have these at your disposal.
Now let's do the next step which is
a force balance.
That comes out of postulate three.
Out of postulate three it says
Newtonian mechanics applicable.
Let's put a force balance. I am
going to say if that electron is to
stay in its orbit,
that is to say it doesn't flee the
atom, it doesn't collapse under the
nucleus then the sum of the forces
on the electron must be zero.
No net force. And so that will be
the sum of a dynamic force
plus an electrostatic.
Or just to be pluralistic in our
language, coulombic force.
And so, you know from your
Newtonian mechanics,
as you were learning in 8.
1, the dynamic force here is mv
squared over r.
Again, m is the mass of the
electron. And now the force,
in its most general term is q1q2
over 4 pi epsilon zero,
which is the conversion factor r
squared. Force goes as
one over r squared.
Energy goes as one over r.
And, if you ever get confused,
the way to remember these is that
you know energy is the integral of a
force moving through a distance.
Energy is the integral of force
moving through a distance.
So the integral of one over r
squared gives you one over r.
If you get them backwards, you will
integrate one over r and will get
log r. That makes no sense.
So there we are.
And we plug in our values and end up
with mv squared over r minus Ze
squared over 4 pi epsilon zero r
squared. And I am going to call
this equation two.
That is our force balance.
And then, for the next piece of
information, I am going to go to
postulate number five.
And postulate number five is some
of Bohr's early genius.
Bohr says that the energy is
quantized through its
angular momentum.
He is talking about the energy of an
electron. No one,
until this time, had suggested that
a system would be subjected to
quantization except for light.
Planck had already enunciated back
in 1900 this e equals h nu.
In other words, that the photon has
a quantum of energy h nu.
So quantization of radiation was
already established
as of about 1900.
But no one dared say we have this
little planetary model,
I've got an electron orbiting a
central nucleus and I am going to
endow that electron with quantized
states. That was a big leap and
that was Bohr in postulate five.
Postulate five I am just going to
reproduce. That is mvr,
which is its angular momentum,
does not take continuous values.
It takes discrete values, multiples
of some integer n,
and the multiplication factor is the
ratio of the Planck constant divided
by 2 pi where n takes one,
two, three and so on.
And I am going to call this one
equation three.
So I have three equations and three
unknowns. And I am not going to
take the time to solve it because I
think that is a waste of class time,
but those are the three unknowns.
The radius of the orbit,
the energy of the system and the
velocity of the electron,
I am just going to present you the
solutions. Let's look first of all
at the radius of the orbit.
If you solve for r,
you will end up with this.
This is the permittivity of vacuum.
Square of the Planck constant times
pi mass of the electron.
I am going to stop putting
subscript e. It is the mass of the
electron. Times the square of the
elementary charge times n squared
over Z. Z is the proton number,
number of protons in the nucleus.
What do I see?
I see that r takes on discrete
values. R is a function of n and
takes on discrete values.
And, in fact, the functionality is
that of the square of this number
times a constant.
So this tells us that the radius of
the electron orbit,
first of all, there is more than one
radius. There is a plurality of
values. Secondly,
that those values are discrete.
They are quantized.
And, third, it is nonlinear.
If I look at something that goes as
n squared, if this is the edge of
the nucleus here and if this is r1,
it says when n goes to two the
radius goes to four.
Let's say this is r1,
this is r2 and then this will be r3
and this will be r4.
And even that is not to scale.
The higher the n number the greater
the radius by far.
And this applies to all one electron
atoms. Let's look at the simplest
case. Suppose we look at elemental
hydrogen. In the case of elemental
hydrogen, Z will equal one.
And then let's look at the lowest
orbit, n equals one.
That is the electron in its lowest
orbit to the nucleus of atomic
hydrogen. And this lowest orbit is
termed the ground state.
First floor. If we put one here and
one here, the value is simply given
by this constant.
And if you evaluate the constant
you get that r1 is equal to 5.
9 times 10 to the minus 11 meters or
0.529 angstroms.
I like the angstrom.
It is 10 to the minus 10 meters.
It is not an SI unit because it is
not a multiple of 10 to the 3rd,
but I like the angstrom.
I don't like the nanometer.
I like the angstrom because atomic
dimensions are conveniently measured
by angstroms. And this is given a
special symbol A nought.
It is the value of the radius of
the ground state electron orbit in
atomic hydrogen.
And this quantity is termed the
Bohr radius. And you don't even
have to look it up.
Because it, too,
is given on your Table of Constants.
There is the Planck Constant,
number five. There is the Bohr
radius down there,
number 24. So you just look that up.
And anything else is going to be
some multiple of it.
The other thing I would like to
draw your attention to is this.
I can simplify this in the
following manner and say that r n,
now that I have a Bohr radius for
this bracketed quantity,
I can write that as the product of
the Bohr radius for the value of the
orbit in any one electron atom.
Specify the quantum number n and
divide by Z. That is this rewritten
in a much more compact notation
because you have the value of this.
And note that as Z increases, as
the proton number increases the
radius decreases for a given n
number. If you look at the ground
state in two different systems --
If you look at the ground state
which is n equals one,
think about this, if I increase the
proton charge,
the Coulombic force of attraction is
greater. And so,
therefore, all other things being
equal, the first orbit should be at
a smaller distance.
So this is making physical sense.
Now let's look at energy. Let's
quantify the energy value.
If you go through and solve for
energy, you will get this equation.
E is equal to minus mass of the
electron times the elementary charge
raised to the fourth power divided
by e times the square of the
permittivity of vacuum times the
square of the Planck constant times
Z squared over n squared.
Again, we see that e is a function
of n. You see,
the quantum condition,
by putting quantization into the
angular momentum it is propagated
through the entire system.
Orbit dimensions are quantized.
Energy is quantized. Velocity is
quantized. Everything is quantized.
Energy is quantized. It has a
different n dependence.
If I lump all of this together in
some constant,
I can then represent that formula as
minus K times Z squared over n
squared where n again chooses
integer values one, two,
three and so on.
And we can go through and calculate
the value of this quantity in
parenthesis. And,
when we do so, we get the value 2.
8 times 10 to the minus 18 joules.
This is 10 to the minus 18 joules
for this one atom.
I am going to draw attention to
this. It is joules per atom.
Or, if you multiply by Avogadro's
number then you will
get joules per mole.
And if you do so,
you will end up with 1.
12 mega joules per mole for this
quantity K. And you can find that
one, too. That is on your chart.
If you multiply entry 23, which is
13.6 electron volts,
I will show you what the electron
volt is in a few minutes.
We will just put it up here
prematurely. But that is given in
your chart. And then the conversion
of joules to electron
volts is entry 42.
If you multiply those two together
you will end up with this quantity.
And so let's take a look at what
that does in terms of graphical
representation.
I tried to give you a simple
graphical representation.
That was Cartesian space.
When I plot r as a distance out
from the nucleus that is sort of our
simple-minded planetary model.
Now let's look at energy. I am
going to put energy in
the following manner.
It is a conservative system so all
the energies are negative.
That quantity in parenthesis,
I have a mass which is a positive
number. Something raised to the
fourth power has got to be positive.
Something raised to the second
power has got to be positive.
Everything inside the parenthesis
is positive, so minus a positive
number. All the energies are
negative because it is a bound
system. I start up here with n
equals one. And over here this is
the value of minus K.
And then, if we go to n equals two,
what happens? We go to n equals two
for a fixed value of Z.
Let's make this Z equals one.
We will do it for atomic hydrogen.
It is K over four. And then we go
to n equals three.
And this is not to scale.
And so on. This is what the energy
level diagram looks like.
This is for atomic hydrogen gas.
And I am going to put on here "not
to scale." There are some relative,
the notion that the energy gap
between n equals one and n equals
two is greater than that for n
equals two to n equals three.
That is correctly represented.
These are definitely not equally
spaced, but they should be even more
disproportionate than I have shown
it. And finally up here we have n
equals infinity.
When n equals infinity,
r equals infinity.
And so the energy is zero because
the electron is no longer bound.
It is free. The electron has been
liberated. This represents the free
electron. It is no longer tethered
to the nucleus so there is no energy
stored in the system.
And the closer it gets to the
nucleus the greater the amount of
energy, which means that you see
this in the following manner.
This is called the ground state,
n equals one. I already mentioned
that. It's like the ground floor.
I know some of you come from Europe
and other parts of the world where
the ground floor is rez-de-chaussée
or some silly thing like this and
you push a button on the elevator to
one and you go up to the first floor.
You are in American now,
and the International Chemical
Community calls the ground state n
equals one, not n equals zero.
Please observe the traditions of
the International Union of Pure and
Applied Chemistry, not
to mention Niels Bohr.
So this is ground state,
these are the excited states and
free electron at n equals infinity.
And, at this point, we say that the
atom has become ionized.
That is to say an electron has been
ejected. And so now we have net
charge. And we can calculate the
ionization energy.
The ionization energy must then be
nothing more than,
that is the energy to go from the
ground state here to n equals
infinity, so that would be the
energy at state infinity minus the
energy of the ground state.
Well, the energy at infinity is
zero and the energy in the ground
state is minus K.
So minus minus K is plus K.
K, in fact, is the ionization
energy. And, in fact,
if you go to the chart,
to your Periodic Table indeed there
it is.
This is a slightly different version
from the one you have,
but it is the same order.
If you look on the Periodic Table
this is atomic hydrogen.
And, sure enough, there is 13.
98, which is this number here in
electron volts.
That is the ground state energy of
atomic hydrogen.
The other thing to note is look at
the dependence upon Z.
Suppose instead of hydrogen we
considered lithium 2plus.
Lithium 2plus is a one electron atom.
Lithium has three electrons.
If it loses two one remains. What
is this formula telling us?
It is telling us that the ground
state in lithium would be Z squared.
It would be nine times more intense.
It would be nine times less.
That is to say minus nine is less
than minus one.
And that makes sense,
too, because the positive three
pulling on minus one has a tighter
binding energy than positive one
pulling on minus one.
So this drops by the square,
whereas, you saw how the orbit goes.
Just picking up on this ionization
energy. The ionization energy we
can define, this is the minimum
energy to remove an electron from
the ground state of an
atom in the gas phase.
All the things we are talking about
here are with reference to the gas
phase. Gas phase single atom.
So we don't have to deal with work
function or any kind of energies
associated with some condensed form
of matter. So we are really looking
at this reaction here for ionization.
It is H gas neutral goes to H plus
in the gas phase plus the electron.
And, furthermore,
we can have multiple ionization
energies. If you have multiple
electrons we can lose them in
sequence. For example,
I could look at the ionization of
lithium. Again,
lithium gas loses an electron to
become lithium ion plus electron.
I can then subsequently lose an
electron from the lithium ion.
Lithium ion loses an electron to
become lithium 2plus.
And then a lithium 2plus still has
an electron. Let's denude lithium
2plus. So lithium 2plus loses its
electron. This is the analogy to
the alpha particle.
The alpha particle was the helium
nucleus. This is the lithium
nucleus plus electron.
We call these first, second,
third ionization energies in
sequence. This is the first
ionization energy.
This is the second ionization energy.
That is to say the ionization
energy of the second most electron.
And this is the third ionization
energy. Now, where do we find these
values? Well,
if we look on the chart,
the first ionization energy is what
is reported in your Periodic Table.
The first ionization energy of
lithium is about 5.4 electron
volts per atom.
We can get this from the Periodic
Table, so reported is Periodic Table.
And this is determined by
measurement. This one here,
I cannot do anything for you.
You will have to look that one up.
What about this one? This one is
calculable by the Bohr model because
lithium 2plus is a one electron
system. I just go through these
equations, but be careful to put in
Z equals three.
And I can calculate this from Bohr
model. Let's say calculable by Bohr
model. And then remember Z equals
three. I am showing some
versatility here.
And, let's see, we've talked about
radius, we've talked about energy.
Let's talk about velocity just for
completeness.
So the velocity is given by this
product of the quantum number n
Planck constant 2 pi mass of the
electron times the radius of the
orbit, which itself is a function of
n. We can make some substitutions
here using some of the derivation on
the previous board which will give
us the Planck constant divided by 2
pi mass of the electron
times the Bohr radius.
All of this times the ratio of Z
over n where n equals one,
two, three and so on
**v=hZ/(2*pi*m*a0*n)**.
And we rarely look at velocity
because, as you will learn very
quickly in 3.091,
we are going to abandon this strict
adherence to a planetary model
pretty soon. But it is interesting.
Let's just, for an order of
magnitude say what happens for
ground state electron
in atomic hydrogen?
So we are going to put atomic
hydrogen Z equals one,
ground state n equals one.
That is just this quantity here.
So let's find out. V1 in atomic
hydrogen, is it fast?
Is it slow? What is the number?
Plug in the values. You get 2.18
times 10 to the plus 6 meters per
second, which is about 1% of the
value of the speed of light.
By the way, c,
the value of speed of light,
in case you cannot remember it,
is the number one entry in your
Table of Constants.
So 1% the speed of light.
I would say that is relatively fast.
That is a pun.
I think about this as relatively
fast. You people have no sense of
humor, no sense of joy,
no sense of joie de vivre.
You are so young. You've only been
here a week and are so jaded.
You've got four years to go.
So where does c come from? How
come the speed of light has the
symbol c? Where is the symbol c?
It comes from the Latin word
celeritas which means swiftness.
We get the English word accelerate
from the same root word.
That is why we have one.
That's why we have c. We are in
pretty good shape here.
We have a Bohr model, which is
quantitative.
It makes predictions that can be
tested. We have energies.
We have radii. Is there any
experimental evidence that can put
this to the test?
And the answer is yes.
In the early 1850s, Angstrom,
up at the University of Uppsala in
Sweden was conducting experiments on
atomic hydrogen.
He was doing experiments in a gas
discharge tube.
He had a tube with electrodes
potted in it filled with
atomic hydrogen.
And by applying a voltage,
he was able to get the gas to glow.
And then he analyzed the components
of that radiation and this is what
he found. First of all,
let's take a look at his experiment.
There it is. He used the prism
spectrograph to analyze his results.
So what do we have here? Here is
the gas discharge tube.
This is the diagram taken right
from your text,
there are the two electrodes coming
in and this is atomic hydrogen
in the gas tube.
And so if he gets the voltage high
enough, this gas discharge tube will
glow. And the light will be going
in all directions,
obviously. It is a glass tube.
He wants to narrow the light so he
puts a couple of slits here.
And then he just takes that narrow
column of light and he admits it to
a prism. And what the prism does is
takes a tiny, tiny difference in
wavelength and refracts it through a
different angle.
And if the prism is of sufficient
dimension that angle can be
magnified. And then further you put
some recording device,
which in those days was a
photographic plate,
far across a room. So you take a
tiny, tiny angle and you go far
enough across the room.
And now you get separation on the
order of centimeters.
And we record here. And this is
the blowup of what is on that
photographic plate.
And this was painstaking work.
What you have here is the
photographic plate demonstrating
a spread.
First of all, the glow is made up of
constituents. There are distinct
lines here. What appears to the
naked eye to be just glowing is
actually superposition of different
lines of distinct frequency.
So, you see, this is quantized.
And so he published his results
around 1853. And so
they lay. 1853.
Let's get Angstrom up on the board
here since he did the work.
He was Uppsala, in Sweden. He
measured the line spectra of atomic
hydrogen. By the way,
your text has a glaring error.
The label above this figure refers
to H2.
Take the fattest marking pen you
have, scratch that out and replace
it with atomic hydrogen.
You do not get this line from
molecular hydrogen.
We have the line spectra lying out
there in the literature,
and people read the literature.
They read. And one of the people
that was reading this literature was
a high school teacher who was
teaching mathematics in
Basil, Switzerland.
This man also had the initials J.
. as in J.J. Thompson. This is J.
. Balmer. And J.J. Balmer in 1885
playing with the numbers associated
with the lines there,
you notice how the lines are colored?
Your book isn't colored.
See, I colored them for you.
I care about you. I wanted to
illustrate that this is representing
different wavelengths in the visible.
And the doctor told me it is good
for me to express my creative urges.
So I got out my pen and I did that.
Where was I? What Balmer did, all
he has is those four numbers.
He has the wavelengths of those
four numbers. And he is playing
with those numbers.
He is determined to make sense of
those four numbers in some kind of a
sequence, and this is what he came
up with finally.
He came up with the relationship
that nu bar, which is
called wave number --
He found the reciprocal.
What he did was coined this.
But he found that by taking the
reciprocal of the wavelengths,
you have four numbers, he took the
reciprocals of those wavelengths and
found that they fit a numerical
sequence. One over two squared
minus one over n squared where n
takes values three, four, five, six.
And there is a constant out here.
And the constant, if we redo it in
modern SI units,
would take on the value of 1.
times 10 to the 7th reciprocal
meters. How does this support
the Bohr model?
Well, in order to answer that
question, I have to give you a
little more background information.
The first thing I have to do is
give you the understanding of the
physics of the gas discharge tube.
Let's take a look inside that tube.
Let me redraw it. I am going to
redraw it horizontally.
This is a glass tube. There are
some feedthroughs here to allow
electrodes to be potted.
These are gas-tight feedthroughs.
And these electrodes are then
connected to a variable voltage
power supply. And it is possible to
change the voltage on the plates.
And the way I have this configured,
the left electrode is going to be
charged negatively and the right
electrode is going to be charged
positively. So the left electrode
will be the cathode as I have
configured it,
and the right electrode will be
anode.
And what is inside the gas discharge
tube is gas at low pressure.
As we increase the voltage, we get
to a critical value at which it is
possible to actually draw electrons
across the gap.
Electrons will actually boil off
the cathode and accelerate across.
You have a positive electrode here
and the electron is charged
negatively. It will be drawn to the
positive electrode.
So it will accelerate from rest and
crash into the anode.
If we have nothing here,
we see nothing. If we have too much
gas in here, in other words,
if the gas is at too high a pressure,
the collisions with the gas
molecules will consume the energy of
the electrons and,
again, we will see nothing.
If we get the pressure in there
just right, we will allow for gas
electron collisions and then we get
the glow that ultimately was sent
through the slits.
That is the operation of the gas
discharge tube.
Now let's look at the physics.
What is the energy of the electron,
the energy of this electron
accelerating from rest and crashing
into the anode here?
Well, it is going to be mechanical.
One-half mv squared. And how about
potential energy? It is not bound.
It is a free electron so there is no
potential energy to be accounted for.
So it is simply one-half mv squared.
But I can equate the amount of
mechanical energy in the electron to
the amount of electrical energy that
was imparted through the electrodes.
And the electrical energy is the
product of the charge on the
electron times the voltage which is
the potential difference through
which the electron was accelerated.
And so this allows me to,
by increasing the voltage,
increase the energy on the electron.
You can see low voltage, low energy,
high voltage, high energy.
It is a linear function. And how
about order of magnitude?
Let's see. Let's do everything
unit. That is a good way.
What is the unit charge? The
smallest charge I could put here
would be 1.6 times 10 to the minus
19 coulombs. And what if I took a
unit charge and I multiplied it
times unit voltage, one volt?
Unit charge times unit voltage then
would give me what?
If I multiply these two,
what is the coulomb times a volt?
Here is the value of using SI units.
SI units means everything goes in,
in SI, everything comes out in SI.
What is the energy unit in SI?
The joule. What is the unit of
charge in SI? Coulomb.
What is the unit of potential
difference? Volt.
With impunity.
If I use coulombs here and volts
here, I don't even think.
I write 1.0 times 1.6. Even that I
can do in my head.
That is 1.6 times 10 to the minus
19 and I write joules.
That is the power of having a
rationalized system of units.
That is the good news. The bad
news is I hate this number.
Look it. 1.6 times 10 to the minus
18, excuse me,
we have 1.6 times 10 to the minus 19,
2.18 times 10 to the minus 18,
etc. Cannot we get simple numbers
like three and seven?
Whatever happened to good-old
numbers? I have an idea.
Why don't we define a new unit of
energy that is nearer to what we
have to measure?
And that was done.
What people did is they said let's
define a unit of energy that
represents a unit charge accelerated
across a unit potential difference,
and let's call that the electron
volt. That is one electron volt.
The electron volt is not a unit of
potential difference.
It is a unit of energy.
Now, this is 1.0 eV. Now you can
see 2.18 times 10 to the minus 18
joules can be 13.
eV. Now, I don't have to fill my
head with 2.18 times 10 to the minus
18. 13.6, that's a cool number.
I can remember that. That is how
that works. By the way,
this is the cathode.
And we have a beam.
It is an electron beam.
In the 1890s, the latter part of
the 19th century a very fashionable
word was "ray."
Because it came from optics,
you know, rays of sunlight and so on.
And, in fact,
even when we first started pulling
synthetic fiber,
the first synthetic fiber cellulose
was referred to as rayon because it
looked like a ray that
was being pulled.
So rather than calling this an
electron beam,
this was called a cathode ray.
And this was a tube at low pressure.
And if I evacuate it,
I have a cathode ray tube.
And, in fact, instead of having
just an electrode here,
what I could do is I could have an
electrode that is hollow.
And then I could put a flat end
here and I could put
phosphorus here.
And then I could put a couple of
plates and I could raster the beam
so that when I am looking here the
beam goes back and forth about 80
times a second.
And the phosphorus glow.
And I can be watching a science
documentary.
All right. The other thing I have
to teach you is matter-energy
interaction so that we can see how
the Balmer series validates the Bohr
model. So there is one more thing
you need to know.
And I am going to put up this
energy level diagram again.
This is infinity. Let's call this
3, 2, 1. This is E1 ground state,
E2, E3 and so on. And this is zero.
Let's look at the energetics of one
of those electrons crashing into a
hydrogen atom inside the gas tube.
Here is an electron. And I am
going to let this arrow somehow
indicate the value of the incident
energy. And I am saying electron,
but more generally it applies to any
incident particle.
Later on we could do this with a
proton. We could do it with a
neutron. Rutherford used alpha
particles. We could use argon ion.
There are all kinds of different
ways of bombarding,
in this case, hydrogen gas.
Now, if this incident energy is
great enough it will take an
electron out of the ground state and
promote it. But the electron cannot
reside anywhere except in one of
these quantized states.
Suppose the E incident is greater
than the energy in the transition
going from ground state to n equals
two. What will happen?
That energy will be absorbed by the
hydrogen atom,
the electron will rise from n equals
one to n equals two.
And that amount of energy will be
subtracted. And then over here this
electron will continue.
And I have purposely made the arrow
shorter to indicate that it has been
slowed because we are going to argue
its mass didn't change,
so the only way to change its energy
is to change its velocity.
This will we call scattered now.
It's interacted. This is the
scattered particle.
But it doesn't end there.
So how much energy is there?
Let this represent the total energy
of the incident electron.
And if that is the energy to go from
n equals one to n equals two then
this is the amount of energy that
has to be left as kinetic energy of
the electron. It is like an elastic
collision between billiard balls.
You've seen these things. But it
doesn't end there because the
electron is sitting up here at n
equals two very nervous because
there is a lower energy state and
there is a coulombic attraction to
the nucleus. So what happens almost
instantaneously after the collision,
the electron up here falls back down.
And when it falls back down that
energy is given off.
And it is given off in the form of a
photon. And what is the energy of
that photon? Well,
the energy of the photon,
we know from Planck, is h nu,
which is hc over lambda. Now I have
lambdas associated with transitions
between energy levels
in atomic hydrogen.
Gee, I wonder if I could come up
with a set of transitions occurring
inside atomic hydrogen that just
might match what Angstrom measured
back in 1853. That is going to be
the challenge.
The interesting thing here is that
I can change the incident
velocity continuously.
This is continuously variable
because I can vary voltage
continuously. Change the voltage,
I change the incident energy. What
about the energy of the emitted
photons? Are they continuously
variable? No,
they are discrete.
They are discrete.
And, furthermore, they are
characteristic of the target gas
element. Let's say I got up late
and I am racing to get to class.
I just burst in now,
I look up there and go that's atomic
hydrogen. Because only atomic
hydrogen has that set of lines which
means I could then take the spectra
of gas phase species and use that
information to identify.
This is now a technique of analysis.
I could take an unknown gas and put
it in and measure it and then say,
wow, those are the lines that are
characteristic of sodium.
Gee, have you ever wondered how they
know the composition of stars that
are light-years away?
Do they get sample bottles coming
in? How do they get that
information? What is a star,
if not just a giant gas bottle,
containerless? It is glowing. And
why is it glowing?
It is glowing because electrons are
excited.
And they are excited and they are
jumping up and down and they are
emitting. But they are just not
emitting anything.
I mean, why are some stars this
color and some stars that color?
Did somebody paint them that way?
They are different because they
have different compositions.
So you could use this in order to
identify the contents of stars.
All of this. What did Bohr do?
I want to tell you a couple more
Bohr stories. The guy was great.
Here is what happens. Here is a
story.
Capstone of Bohr's work on the
Balmer formula.
Let me simply tell you that in time
I am going to show you that this
formula is inconsistent with the
Bohr model. You will see that at
the beginning of next lecture.
In 1896, Charles Pickering from
Harvard found a series of lines in
starlight which he attributed to
hydrogen, even though they did not
fit Balmer. They were off by a
factor of four.
Now, what do you know about energy?
Already from this class,
if I told you that I gave you
energies in some spectrum but they
were off by a factor of four,
what would you think? Maybe the Z
is wrong. So,
even though the lines were wrong,
he says, no, that is hydrogen. Bohr
says, no, that is not hydrogen.
It is helium. That star has
ionized helium,
helium plus. Z equals two.
Energy will be four times more
intense.
Pickering was a nasty SOB and said
you are wrong.
Because, in fact,
it is 4.0016. And the 0.
016 is greater than what I would
have as experimental error,
so your theory is wrong. Bohr says
oh, yeah? He goes back and redoes
the calculation,
only in this case he says what I am
going to do is I am going to redo
the calculation for helium,
but I am going to consider not just
the mass of the electron but the
reduced mass of the system.
So I will take into account that
there is some contribution of both
the nucleus and the electron.
And he gets, you are absolutely
right, it is not 4.
, it is 4.00163. Take that.
What you have is with a simple
calculation five significant figures.
That shut him up.
Now, just to show it doesn't end,
more nonsense at Harvard. This is
Cecilia Payne.
First woman graduate student in
astronomy. First PhD in astronomy.
First woman to receive tenure at
Harvard. She was awarded tenure in
1938, denied a professorship for 18
years, and when she presented her Ph.
thesis she was the one that
determined that the sun is made
dominantly of hydrogen,
not ion, the way most of the old
goats thought.
Because the earth is made of iron,
heaven knows everything is made of
the same stuff,
all heavenly bodies.
Even though the sun is glowing and
the earth isn't,
but they must be made of the same
thing.
And, after all,
we are Harvard so we know.
Here is what she did. She was
fastidious. Look at this.
What do you see there? Well,
you see iron. But this is
misspelled. You would make an
excuse and say the detector isn't
working. This is a noisy system.
That is what everybody else is
doing. But what Cecilia is doing is
saying I have got to keep looking.
I need a consistent picture. This
is what spectroscopy is.
Spectroscopy is how you go and look
at patterns, not just individual
lines. When she defended her thesis,
she was forced to put this phrase in
her thesis. "The enormous abundance
of hydrogen is almost certainly not
real." This is the way science
welcomes newcomers.
This is the way science on some
occasions welcomes new findings.
Just up the street.
And I am not talking about the 1600s.
This was in the ‘30s.
This is a painting of her.
Dudley Herschbach, a Harvard
chemistry professor who has a Nobel
prize had this painting hung at one
of the halls. And it is obviously
referential to Vermeer's "The
Astronomer." We have come a long
way from the gas discharge
tube to the heavens.
But it shows you that with a little
bit of understanding of quantization
you can go a long way.
OK, we will see you Friday.